have got it now okay it's 110 Pages this
is the bundle that's been submitted that
has been published by the committee
Boris Johnson's team have seen
um so far I can see that it contains a
lot of evidence about what the rules
were at the time of each of the
Gatherings that Boris Johnson attended
so I'll be looking through a fine-tooth
comb about what the rules were that he'd
announced so should have known about and
we are gonna getting into his messages
with number 10 officials so I'll look at
those very carefully and come back to
you okay so he one of the other defenses
of the uh prime minister is that he has
the heavy burden of leadership at the
time and he had no time to worry about
what was happening with gatherings in
Downing Street he also says that he was
challenged by the architecture of the
building he didn't actually say that but
that shorthand for what he was
suggesting it's a townhouse dining
Street his number 10 Downing Street is a
Georgian building it's it's quite narrow
it's a terrorist building and he's
saying because it's so small and
hundreds of people were working there at
the time of course he would walk through
rooms where people were gathered he
thought working he would stop he would
have a moment to chat to them but the
burden of leadership meant that he
didn't have time to ask whether they
were having a party and when he was told
by his team they would say no no it's
not a party prime minister we're just
going to crack on and we're trying to
make sure that people are kept safe
during lockdowns and this period over 18
months or so with covid and the pandemic
so I'm sure we'll be hearing more about
that from the Prime Minister as he gives
that four hours plus of evidence later
on today the question that will have to
be answered is
did the Prime Minister know what he said
at the dispatch box at the time in
December of 2021 the first and the 8th
of December 2021 did he know at the time
what he said was untrue or
ought he to have known at the time when
he made those statements that what he
was saying was willfully misleading
Parliament
let's have a look at the documents
should we here we go
this is a document tomorrow that has
been released within the last few
moments and this is based on it's a lot
of pages I know you told me I've
forgotten 100 pages so yeah and this is
based on what the Prime Minister and his
legal team just remember quarter of a
million quid is what it's cost of
taxpayers so far and then of course
there's the cost on the other side as
well so I'm guessing we're pushing half
a million pounds or thereabouts
um and this is sort of I suppose a
synopsis of what we might see later on
today absolutely so this is evidence
that the committee and Boris Johnson
will rely on so in the first 30 pages
that I've looked through they are
talking about what the rule remember how
the rules just constantly were updated
and changed and there was guidance as
well and what it was at the time and
they're relying a lot on what Boris
Johnson himself said to Parliament for
example in uh in May 2020 he's talking
he's asked about workplaces and said
it's essential that people observe the
rules on social distancing as well as on
masks and everything else it was
enforcement and by architecture at
number 10 meant yes some challenges so
they are so they're looking at when he
was asking the comments about workplaces
exactly how stringent he personally was
you know workplaces must observe those
rules and social distancing and Boris
Johnson relying in his defense yesterday
uh on the fact that he thought that that
the guidance these are pictures that we
we have seen before actually the start
of this month of some of those
Gatherings they give quite a different
impression to the the phone not a party
though as far as he was concerned well
this was a leaving do
um he was not fined over this one he was
only fined over one which was the
birthday party but he says it wasn't a
party just to just to can we clarify
this as far as our viewers are concerned
this morning uh because you're the font
of all knowledge here tomorrow he
accepted a police fine he could have
challenged that in the courts he didn't
he accepted his guilt at the time so he
paid the fine and it's um been pointed
out that these are the summary fines and
and lots of other people who got these
fines were not not able to to challenge
them and and often will find large
amounts of money and he he interestingly
in the in the in the messages that we
saw yesterday with his number 10 staff
he actually refers at one point to a
party and he says that that was a
shorthand because that's what was being
used in the media but they certainly
between themselves refer to some of
these gatherings as parties
um so this so far we've got a detailed
explanation of the rules and what Boris
Johnson was saying
um at every at every stage
um I think we get it's all clarify again
sorry tomorrow but we're looking at all
of this stuff on screen as we're talking
to you what is this actually telling us
well people will will the commissee with
Boris Johnson and his uh silk uh next to
him they'll be going through this by
Point by point or is this just
background information so they've got
all this already this was um This was
um evidence that
um the the committee has the committee
has spoken to a number of former and
current number 10 staff some of whose
names are published and some of whom are
kept Anonymous and they have gathered
lots of evidence about who said what to
Boris Johnson not just in advance of the
Gatherings as in was anyone warning him
not sure about this one but also in the
run up to his appearances in Parliament
when he said I was assured all the
guidance was followed was there any
suggestion that he was warned it hadn't
been so these are all the all the
evidence that they've gathered is in
some well not all of it Boris Johnson's
team say there is some that isn't um in
here but they um a lot of these raw
messages and pages of the guidance at
every stage are being published here and
they're both going to rely on on the
evidence here Boris work with me here
tomorrow page 61 Martin Reynolds we're
winging this as we go trying to update
you this is written evidence there you
go it's on the screen for you know um
tomorrow I do recall asking the then
prime minister about the proposed live
floor please yeah yeah this is this is
very interesting this is the day before
the Yankees yeah referred to the media
as party Marty organize the garden party
the controversial Gardener party in May
for which Boris Johnson wasn't fine but
we understand other people were he says
in giving evidence to inquiry in
February a month ago I do recall asking
the then prime minister about the line
proposed for pmqs on the 7th of December
it was the day before he said no rules
were broken suggesting all rules and
guidance hadn't been followed I cannot
remember exactly when I did this but I
believe it would have been in the period
roughly an hour before pm queues on the
7th when the Prime Minister would have
been preparing on his own as he usually
did he did not welcome the interruption
but told me he'd received reassurances
at the comms event was within the rules
I accepted this but questioned whether
it was realistic to argue all guidance
had been followed at all times given the
nature of the working environment in
number 10 he agreed to delete the
reference to the guidance however when
he answered a question in pmqs later on
he did go back to that exact line and
what he's so this is really interesting
because yesterday in Boris Johnson's
defense he said that the line prepared
by the Press office was all the
regulations and the rules were following
all the new Eagle stuff was followed
here we have his private secretary
someone very important to him in number
10 saying that he asked him to delete
the line about the guidance Boris
Johnson then went to the House of
Commons and perhaps In the Heat of the
Moment said all the guidance was
followed but he didn't say that when he
first stood at the dispatch box it was
in answer to a question so it's
obviously in his mind but he had been
told by someone very senior not sure
about the guidance bit isn't that a bit
you know can't that be stretched to
include some of the issues in number 10
so when Boris Johnson then said in the
Commons the guidance was followed was he
being intentionally misleading I think
that's what the committee will be
putting to him today and that's going to
be crucial because they're looking for
evidence of intentionally misleading or
recklessly misleading I.E should he have
not
drawn on his memory of these gatherings
and thought something was a bit off so
if either of those things are found to
be correct then he faces a severe
sanction and it has implications for his
political career so um so messages like
this from Martin Reynolds very close all
over the Prime Minister saying delete
that bit about the guidance I'm sure
that will Merit a lot of questions today
okay and just to clarify for people just
tuning our way we are looking at a
document that's about 110 Pages longer
is literally just dropped it's from the
Privileges committee releasing the party
gate evidence it's public information
tomorrow yes it is yes this is all
published publicly on the website
everyone can have a look at it okay
um 110 Pages this is the synopsis of
what will be happening later on is my
understanding and this is what the Prime
Minister will be potentially saying to
the committee the committee have
questions of their own as a result of
the document that was given to them late
on Monday evening by the Prime Minister
50 odd pages is that was collated as a
result of his time with his defense team
now just to remind you it will be on Sky
News this whole live event from two
o'clock this afternoon it's likely to
take at least four hours is what we're
being told there will be a break uh
early on from when it starts in order
for the MPS that are gathering there in
the Privileges committee for
conservatives and then labor s p and
libden representatives as well remember
that the chairman of the committee is a
female labor MP Harriet Harman she has
been seconded on to the committee as a
result of the chairman who had been
previously negative uh in his comments
about the Prime Minister Chris Bryant he
recused himself he stepped down in other
words in order to try to have this
committee as a level-headed and as
balanced as possible those MPS will be
leaving in order to have a quick vote on
the latest aspect of the Northern
Ireland protocol recently known as The
Windsor framework and then there will be
uh walking back to the committee room
and continuing on we've heard from the
chairperson we've been hurrying from the
chairperson of the committee who says
that she will expect the prime minister
to answer as many questions as they have
and she will expect him to sit there and
answer all of these questions until they
are bored of asking them Lucy tell me
more
Lee Kane the page 34 the UK yes so Lee
Kane who was basically the interface
between the Prime Minister and the press
and thus the public so he was the
director of of communication he was he's
the prime minister's director of
communications
um at the at the beginning of this
period in the first lockdown now this is
during the period of the garden party
when Martin Reynolds sent an invitation
to dining Street staff to have some
drinks in the garden at the end of a
tough week now we did know that Lee Kane
had expressed concerns about this and he
says that in January uh you said the
cabinet office team that's Sue Gray's
team uh that I received an all-staff
email from Martin Reynolds proposing a
social event in the number 10 garden and
the emails tone was social and in breach
of covet guidance so I politely replied
copying in Dominic Cummings and someone
else that having as many as 200 people
in the garden was a mistake and he
should review following the email Martin
immediately came to my office and asked
why I thought it was an error I don't
think we knew that
um stating it would probably be more of
a risk to send a further email canceling
the event on this point we disagreed and
I strongly advise the event should be
canceled
and later in the afternoon Dominic
Cummings he says inform the Prime
Minister we'd argued about this and he
was frustrated he doesn't remember if he
raised it directly with the Prime
Minister essentially we have it's that
line there as well which is really
important he said he would speak to the
Prime Minister but he was sure it was
okay
yeah that this speaks to prime minister
but he was sure it was okay okay so this
is all about the the discuss so the
discussions around this garden party so
this was an email from Martin Reynolds a
gathering was in held in the Downing
Street Garden uh that was the email sent
was just suggesting it was a social
event the Prime Minister attended and
admits attending for about 25 minutes
but he wasn't fined over it but other
people were now here and we and beyond
that page we've got a series of emails
um and and evidence from Martin Reynolds
um who says that he um he he thinks that
the language he used to invite people to
this event was inappropriate but he
doesn't believe that Lee was saying it
was a breach of the rules only that it
was a comms risk okay it was clear this
is from Lee Kane it was clear observing
all who attended and the layout of the
event in the garden that it was purely a
social function against the rules right
it looks like Lee Kane is saying that it
was against the rules now the prime
minister in his evidence yesterday
claims that he doesn't recall Lee Kane
raising it with him so it doesn't say
that he raised it directly with him does
it yes he doesn't he says he doesn't
raise it directly and he's saying he
raised it verbally so a lot of this will
hinge on whether the committee feel that
there was enough evidence that Lee Kane
did say to him this risks breaching the
rules how many social events events in
Downing Street work or otherwise are we
talking about 14 there were there were
about 15 in total the Prime Minister
attended five of them and those the ones
that are
um being discussed in in the what they
those were the ones that were discussing
the committee's interim report and in
Boris Johnson's evidence yesterday there
were others that went on that he didn't
attend
um or know about page 89 flick through
your list there tomorrow yeah which is
quite tricky on a small phone but here
we go let's have a look what it says
um here we go this is for from somebody
inside number 10 everyone obviously
huddled around you have to remember that
during this whole pandemic number 10 had
not adhered to the rules because we've
just been working where our own bubble
because we don't see anyone outside of
work we're very much our own
bubble and that reflect
that reflects does it not on the
suggestion that you could you could work
as a family or you could be together as
a family bubble that was the guidance
that was being given at the time well so
in the first lockdown this was so I'm
not sure when this is from but in the
first lockdown there was no there were
no bubbles and um this seventh of
February 2023. damaging well this is
when the evidence exactly was came from
but yeah so the
um so I think I think this is talking
about this is talking about events in
November I believe of the first year of
covert now this is damaging because
there was a suggestion from number 10
staff and you can see it here that they
felt the rules didn't apply to them that
they saw each other at work every day
and therefore did not observe social
distancing this is not what the rules or
the guidance said they said that
businesses and workplaces should try to
observe social distancing now Boris
Johnson addressed this in his evidence
yesterday he said there's been a
suggestion we considered ourselves our
own bubble he said that's absolutely not
the case and we did try very hard to
follow the rules within the constraints
of working in a building with small
rooms okay let's deal let's tomorrow if
you would let me um point out the top
um paragraph as well for those of you
watching at home it could be a little
bit small to Target can't it so let me
read it out for you for the benefit of
those who can't read it uh the former
prime minister Boris Johnson often saw
and joined these gatherings this is from
somebody inside number 10 either he was
invited by spads special advisors or
spotted them whilst walking up to his
flat which is above dining Street the
route he took down the corridor looked
Straight Into The Press Room and
vestibules so it's impossible not to see
what was going on he had the opportunity
to shut them down the Gatherings but
joined in made speeches had a drink with
staff he could have taken the issue up
with Martin Reynolds party Marty his
principal private secretary to shut them
down he could see what was happening and
allowed the culture to continue this is
what we're going to be hearing ladies
and gentlemen from two o'clock this
afternoon I know I've got the popcorn
ready tomorrow absolutely I mean this is
this is quite damning and also
um there's more actually on page 39 from
from Dominic Cummings now say what we
like about Dominic Cummings and his sort
of Vendetta against the Prime Minister
but he said the PM certainly knew it was
a drinks party because I told him and
when he walked outside he saw a drinks
party so but he's called Dominic
Cummings a liar he has and says that
he's he's not to be he is not to be
trusted this is that bit from uh from
from Dominic Cummings
um January 22 he said to the cabinet
office investigation team the idea the
PM could have thought this was this
drinks event was work is comical given
the tables covered in bottles of drink
everyone standing around drinking and
the PM certainly knew it was a drinks
party because I told him and when he
went outside he saw a drinks party this
is the garden party in May 2020 when the
the rules and guidance were very strict
and he also told the cabinet office
relating to that same event my memory is
that someone who was highly organized
and competent also questioned the wisdom
of the drinks and definitely will would
have urged Martin channels to check with
the PM whether to go ahead if concerns
and the BYOB bring your own bottle yes
so that we saw the emails related to
that quite shocking last year you know
Martin Reynolds saying it was a drinks
party to thank staff for their efforts
it was not a meeting at which they had a
glass of wine it was a drinks social it
was a social event so whether the Prime
Minister can have known that what were
effectively social events were going on
and then said that all the rules and
guidance were followed will be the will
be the subject of the committee's
question okay you have applied through
that 110 Pages if you would please
tomorrow because there's certainly an
awful lot for us to deal with here don't
forget that we will be covering prime
minister's questions for you at midday
today and I'm sure this will come up
then but the box office uh event is at
two o'clock this afternoon Boris Johnson
evidence session to the party gate
inquiry also known as the Privileges
committee a 7 person committee led by a
labor MP Harriet Harman chair of the
committee let's just let's just listen
as simonizer said in total including
four conservatives this is what Boris
Johnson said on the first and 8th of
December 2021
all guidance was followed uh completely
during number 10. I have been repeatedly
assured since these allegations emerged
that there was no party and that and
that no covid rules were broken I'm
sickened myself and Furious about that
I've said to him that that I have been
repeatedly assured that the rules
the guidance was followed and the rules
were followed at all times